let's just say if you you if you were to
go out and read every single business
book in the world every business book in
the world every biography about a
billionaire how Rockefeller became a
billionaire how Carnegie how if you were
to study every one of these guys there's
still eight skills you couldn't learn
from just reading these books eight
skills you're not going to learn just
from reading these books many times you
guys will ask me questions on snapchat
or Facebook or Twitter and you'll say
Pat here's my predicament here's the
situation I mean what do you think I
should do and my ending message T was
the following John I don't have access
to all the information and I will not
get access to all the information that
you have today this decision you make is
the reason why you will be judged
whether you'll be successful or not so I
don't know what you're going to do but
good luck to you hopefully you'll make
the right decision of people I need your
help with it that's not how it works
you need to make that decision so let's
get right into these eight skill set
number one heart can't be taught number
two having a vision cannot be taught
number three
reading people can't be taught number
four handling pressure on how you handle
pressure it can't be taught number five
judging people cannot be taught number
six
intuition cannot be taught number seven
instinct can't be taught number eight
common sense cannot be taught so you're
watching the same book that I've read
books how to read people man wrote lots
of good books and reading people can't
be taught you can learn the seven
fundamentals of reading people that's
great I've read books on how to judge
people can't be taught can't be taught
these eight things can only be practiced
and caught but they cannot be taught
there are a lot of people like you're
not just for education with a school
thing right on my opinion when I wrote
the book drop on it guess who there's a
lot of people that think just if I just
go to school I'm going to be able to go
and become successful so why is it
there's still such a few percentage of
people have to coming out of college
make six figures why is that if our
educational system works or wiser that
that happens because there's a things
that you cannot teach it can only be cut
so how can it be cut let's talk
because that's probably the question
you're asking let's start off with the
first one crisis crisis forces you and I
to learn some of these skills I didn't
choose to be in a war and be bombed 167
times in a day by Iraq when I was living
in Tehran Iran
I didn't choose that life that's crisis
a person didn't choose to live in a
family where we have a kid that I'm
following every time I want to adopt
this kid because it really hurts me when
I hear the stories this person was going
through that kid cannot sit there and do
anything about the fact that her you
know family's in prison drug overdose
this person has to constantly see that
kid is in crisis mode you see she can't
ever teach you what she's going through
it can only be cut this is crisis right
another one danger zone best ground what
is death ground most people will never
experience death ground what is death
ground this ground is one you go to war
you see so many of these war movies
right and you know that one scene where
they find out about this one soldier
where everybody this most recent movie
they came out with disgust I'm not going
to kill anybody he says I'm not going to
kill it if I'm just going what what's
the movie called hacksaw hacksaw Ridge
where this kid says listen since
everybody's killing each other I think
the least I can do is just save lives
and they found that this guy was the
bravest out of all the other guys you
don't want to kill anybody but he was
the bravest he came everywhere my guy
and everybody's respect and he didn't
kill anybody
that's fire right there but you have to
put him in crisis
desk glance to figure that part out the
other story about still remember the
movie fury with uh with Brad Pitt the
tanks where he tells the kid he says
come on pull the trigger no I can't do
it he starts crying he starts peeing
that's best ground that's crisis that's
pressure that's that type of stuff that
you will never find out about who you
are until if you're in positions like
that you just will not another one is on
life-changing events what's
life-changing events a loss of a loved
one a bankruptcy and absolute you know
challenge and thing that happens in you
family life and your personal life a
certain recovery you make from hell a
hospitalization that almost cost you
everything you know a conference you go
to that completely changes your view
about life then you sit down and you
have a conversation with one human being
that completely shifts the way you look
at life and there's a major paradigm
shift no one can teach that to you
that can only be experienced you can
only sit there you know a lot of people
that way you know move it when you watch
American Gangster with what's the guys
in Frank Lucas writing a Frank Lucas is
around the other guy he has to shadow
this guy to see exactly all this stuff
because that stuff cannot be taught it's
got to be caught
it's got to be caught it's got to be
caught so what am i telling you right
now look unless if you put yourself in
positions where your back is against the
wall I just have to tell you not a lot
is going to happen where you going to
find out these skills it's just not a
lot going to happen you talk to any
major poker player that's a champion now
they're going to tell you at one point
they face somebody that crushed them
that they don't know how to handle they
have to put themselves in best ground
type of situations you talk to any
athlete when Michael Jordan people
started saying oh he's a great one
that shot was shot in North Carolina
they find out this kid's got heart they
find that he can handle pressure man smj
this dude is not afraid of pressure this
guy can handle it when if when you when
your team is down one point and there's
one second left on the shot clock you're
shooting two free-throws they're going
to find that if you're cold as ice
that's pressure that is pressure when
you got to go close this sale or else
you're going to be out of business and
you go in there that's known how to
handle pressure you panic because all
you're thinking about is your bills
bills bills bills bills bills bills and
you don't know how to handle that sales
and you lose it because the client can
tell the fear on your eyes that's
handling pressure so we don't know we
don't know everything about you this
whole thing about life we put so much
stuff about motivation positive thinking
you can go get it there is a chance
maybe you really don't want to go out
there and do it because the last point
I'm going to make in this video is a
very simple point and here's what the
point is listen up very closely
seven billion people are living in the
world we can't measure this we can't
measure your judgment we can measure
your pressure you can measure any of
that stuff but there's one thing that
only you can answer
let me tell what it is if it's important
to you if it's important to you I
guarantee you'll figure it out if it's
not important to you I guarantee you'll
figure it out but that's the part no one
can do anything about not me not the
greatest philosophers of all time not
the greatest minds of all time we put
them all in the room together we said
let's move you we can't do it because we
don't know what's here man we don't know
what you got we don't that's the part
when I message back and I say prove it
show the world what are you all about
you learn these eight things by putting
yourself in crisis situations death
ground back is against the wall you have
to figure out a way to fight like hell
to get out of it
then when you're in that moment and you
say ah I give up yep we just found out
what you're all about and you just find
out what you're all about it's no one's
responsibility but you just figured out
a lot about yourself because I guarantee
if it's important to you you'll figure
that this is why the same family has
four kids and one becomes a rockstar the
other two on they on handle the same
exact from what happened because
somebody it was very important because
to you was very important because to the
other person it was very important only
you can answer that only you can so yes
in a way
these aid can be taught but it can only
be taught if you have the desire to
catch these eight skills if you have no
willingness and the desire to want to
catch these eight skills you're never
going to have them at the highest level
you all everybody already has a little
bit of it but I'm not not at the highest
level we can monetize it in high levels
and really make an impact another
people's lives sha hope today's message
kind of gives you different perspectives
there's a lot of houses on body tamer
but today's message is just kind of
tugging at your heart a little bit
speaking to a little bit like what are
you really made up I'll go show the
world what you're really made up and we
all want to find out what you I'm
talking to you what are you made up up
we want to find out everyone wants to
find out your family wants to find out
your peers want to find out more
importantly your spirit wants to find
out where you got to show to the world
Paul let's get that pillow here this is
an exciting episode man I hope I hope
the right a message was given to you
were steering your soul and maybe even
listen to it one more time and maybe
share this with your team and take notes
on this and start really pause after you
done watching it ask some real questions
of yourself truly how do you handle
pressure ask these questions of yourself
who are you how do you handle these
things hey if you haven't subscribed
after a video like this maybe I didn't
understand cuz you can't hide this is
too much pressure but if you haven't
said you want more videos like this
click sup here and if you haven't joined
a notification squad click on that as
well because you'll be one the first to
get the videos and if you got any
questions comments thoughts about this
video post your comments on the bottom
take care about it provider